nothing's off-limits with the
punishments is that the idea there's
nothing the punishments that you guys
assign there are no limits even though
your friends is that right the only
thing that you kind of get it in by is
the fact that they're gonna get you back
yeah like whatever that they do to me
I'm gonna get them twice as bad that's
an escalation we gotta worry about yeah
right
so you give that a little bit of thought
when you're assigning the punishment
that issue is gonna be on the other foot
at some points or the hairs gonna be on
the other head well maybe we could talk
about that because I don't know I saw
you backstage and you weren't wearing
yeah I was a bald 41 year old man
backstage yeah and here so will you tell
us what what exactly what's going on
with the well I lost an episode about
nine episodes ago and for my punishment
we shaved off 13 inches of Q's hair we
didn't you didn't do any I did nothing I
grew my hair for a year right to 13
inches and then we shaved it high the
best wig maker in New York he's out
there right now yeah $10,000 wig put it
right on his head so that's a wig made
of your hair my hair that is a huge
dying hair it smells like pot and whisky
yeah so as it's worth every penny
exactly yeah now is it really it's a
problem because you have to wear that in
the Sun you guys are you have to wear
that all the time that you're shooting
now yes every day every episode every
challenge every punishment for the past
nine episodes six months now I've had to
wear cues there yeah and on your show
you know what you could do you could
commit a murder and leave the hair at
the team that would be the ultimate
impractical joke got your back is you
spending the rest of your life in the
prisoner
like this isn't funny guys I wasn't
there
you